we haven't heard much about Avengers 4
lately besides some unofficial plot
leaks but besides those everything has
been pretty quiet lately that is until
yesterday when the Russo brothers had an
interview with deadline quick reminder
that the Avengers infinity war blu-ray
giveaway still continues all you have to
do to enter is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero thankfully we finally have an
update for what is happening with
Avengers 4 the Russo brothers in the
interview with deadline said that they
have been working on the edit all summer
for Avengers 4 they also added that they
hope to be in post-production throughout
the fall and winter months the Russo
brothers said that they hope to be done
with everything by March now we have
heard from Dave Bautista that there are
reshoots happening with the recent
firing of James gun Marvel Studios seems
to be struggling to figure out what to
do with the guardians of the galaxy
moving forward seeing as how the
guardians of the galaxy were supposed to
assure in the cosmic future of the MCU
this is a pretty big deal they were
supposed to set up the next 10 to 20
years of the MCU and now guardians of
the galaxy 3 is on permanent hold but
the real question is how does this
affect Avengers 4 here's what Dave
Bautista had to say in an interview with
Digital Spy it's kind of a strange
situation to be in now where we've lost
our director for guardians guardians 3
is really up in the air and I don't know
what they're going to do with it he
thing goes on to say it's on permanent
hold for now and that may make a
difference in what they deal with our
characters in Avengers 4 to be honest
with you right now I really don't know
but I know I've in Avengers 4 I've shot
most of it already I do have two days of
reshoots but other than that I have some
really great scenes that I hope they use
but I guess that it remains to be seen
what they'll do with the characters
hopefully this does not affect Avengers
4 too much and it is most likely that
Marvel Studios already has a little bit
of a grasp of where they want to take
the guardians Marvel has a handful of
great directors that they could use
including the Russo brothers Joss Whedon
and Taika Waititi has already met with
the studio himself this has been widely
speculated to be about directing
guardians of the galaxy 3 although
nothing has come
for sure he did an amazing job at
directing thor ragnarok many fans
actually believe that he saved the thor
franchise so Tycho could definitely be
the man to come in and help Marvel with
their cosmic future of the MCU
not to mention help them with a
guardians of the galaxy and Avengers 4
the Russo brothers seemed fairly
confident that they'll have everything
done by March and as I said they have
tons of great directors on-hand that
could help with the guardians of the
galaxy reshoots for Avengers 4 and help
with the cosmic feature of the MCU what
do you all think about this recent
update from the reso brothers and what
Dave Bautista had to say in his recent
interview let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and again another
reminder about the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]
you